we are continuing our conversation with
Nathan J Robinson who's the editor of
current affairs author of several books
including the current affairs rules for
life and Trump anatomy of a monstrosity
Nathan I I've found your commentary on
the intellectual dark web and on Jordan
Peterson very interesting I saw your
interview over on our friend sam cedars
program the majority report it's so hard
to know where to dig into this but maybe
a place to start is to what do you
attribute the success and popularity of
this movement that is known as the
intellectual dark web is it the people
is it the subject matter is it something
about the timing or something else
altogether well all of the above thing
you know you're asking me a very
difficult question which is it's always
hard to isolate particular causes of
phenomena like these because we can tell
lots of different stories one story is
that there has been like is the story
that they tell which is people are
disgusted with political correctness and
the craziness of the left and so they
flocked to these people who are telling
the truth and who are committed to
reason and facts and logic another story
is well in a world where people don't
know what to believe and where the left
has kind of not offered a coherent
narrative a flock to people like Jordan
Peterson who I think is a self-evident
charlatan but who writes self-help books
and gives gives these sort of adrift
young man meaning in their lives in in a
time where it's difficult to find
meaning you could have a more cynical
explanation on the Left which suggests
that this is just a bubbling up of old
prejudices that this is just a cover
this is just a thin intellectual cover
for our classic racist and sexist
beliefs I'm partially true I don't think
that's completely true though I I'd
offer an explanation that's sort of
partly this is just this is just
conservatism under a new
named and partly it is this sort of you
know in a lat in a world that lacks
ideas a lot of a lot of people the
collapse of universities as vibrant
places of intellectual discussion people
do flock to YouTube philosophers and
these kind of very compelling figures
I mean Peterson even though I say he's a
charlatan is a very compelling figure to
a lot of people and the same even with
someone like ben shapiro who sounds like
he's smart and he's like i'm telling you
the facts and that's and it's always
easy for people that like that to find
an audience they have they have
throughout American history what change
in society could make the popularity of
this movement if you want to call it
that totally disintegrate because I feel
as though what you said isn't all of the
above sort of thing meaning that sort of
the timing and the political climate
right now is a factor in the rise of
this movement I have a hard time
imagining and of course we're terrible
at predicting the future but I have a
hard time imagining that in eight years
time this type of movement with these
particular characters is going to be
what it is today but I don't know
exactly why so I guess I'm curious what
you might think about if society changed
in what way or if what happened would
the sort of niche that they appeal to no
longer give them the popularity that it
provides right now well some of this
some of the intellectual dark web people
so have come out of the new atheist
movement and it's interesting how that
kind of fizzled a little bit and I
always attribute that a little bit to
the way that the climate the social
climate became a little less hostile to
atheism the Christian fundamentalism of
the of the Bush administration kind of
wasn't nearly as present in the in the
right after Bush in the Tea Party and in
Trump and atheism became people felt
less need to be strident atheists and I
I think the same thing where if you
addressed some of the concerns some of
the things
that draw people to this kind of
movement so the hunger for a discussion
of ideas v I mean they do often have
some legitimate complaints about some
ridiculous things the left does some
excesses of you know cultural
appropriation analysis or what-have-you
and if you if you moderate those
tendencies and you you make it so that
you are able to appeal to the people
they might capture I think you can peel
a lot of them off I I mean what I
advocate always I mean I say this over
and over I'm a broken record is building
an alternative
you can't just denounce them but if you
build an alternative that people see as
reasonable then you can you can sort of
neutralize them I'll a talk about that I
want it I want to hear about what would
that alternative look like but in a very
specific way I want to couch that
question because the intellectual
darkweb claims to have significant
political diversity right they say we
are not here because we are liberal or
liberal or conservative you have
right-wingers that that are involved
like ben shapiro do you have sort of the
ambivalent center right I guess
classical liberal maybe is what they
like to call themselves I call it the
ambivalent Center right you have
supposed liberals like brett weinstein i
don't know if eric also considers
himself a liberal maybe he does so they
claim that it's not actually about their
placement on the political spectrum but
that it's about something else so given
that how do you build a successful sort
of alternative to it um well what you
really want i mean i look again you have
to pick who you're trying to persuade i
think there are i think that's probably
true i mean i get emails from people you
know every time i read an article about
one of these guys who say well I
consider myself on the left but I like
these guys because I think they tell it
like it is yeah and I'm not gonna wear
the left is never going to appeal to the
hardcore Shapiro's types but I mean I
think he is like I don't think he's ever
going to change his mind
about these fundamental politics what
you can say is well why are a certain
number of people who identify themselves
as sympathetic to egalitarian
progressive goals why are they being
drawn to someone like Sam Harris who is
like stridently anti-islam who promotes
Charles Murray and and and who's
viciously critical of the contemporary
left what is drawing them to that and
how do we not have that happen and I
think one thing you have to do is you
have to compellingly respond to those
people and if you do and if you offer
the people who might have drifted that
way alternative explanations and you say
well this is why I don't think you
should follow that path this is why I
think our principles are good this is
how we can fix the things that you see
as problems with the left or you say
this is why the things that you think of
problems some of them we don't think of
problems we think are good if you do
that well and you think about you
persuasive power and and and rhetoric
and what and what actually moves people
then I think you could peel off a
segment of those people is this one of
those things where when you consider the
followers of the movement or the
movements of you know kept main
characters as a whole it appears to be
too diverse a group to really influence
with a cohesive single message but when
you consider that the way that politics
works is you've got people who are sort
of committed to one side or the other
and really most political change is
happening with those who are in the kind
of influence or tonn vincible middle or
convince' Buhl's lice then maybe the
strategy becomes much more clear because
you realize there's actually a very
specific person in the middle that
you're sort of trying to appeal to in
order to deflate the entire movement
yeah and so one of the things that you
hear a lot coming out of the
intellectual dark web I still want to
put it in quotes is is that they
disgusted with the left because the left
shuts down speech and won't debate ideas
and won't defend themselves
sure and so I want to prove that wrong
because I think they're partially you
can understand why people would think
that right if they see the left not
responding and just going no free speech
for fascists then you're tempted because
they are saying something that is sort
of grounded in truth but what I want to
do is say well now excuse me
we will debate ideas I'll debate ideas
any day of the week
so in this book the current affairs
rules for life which we just came out
with I mean I go through a series of
them you know Peterson Harris David
Brooks Barry Weiss Heather McDonald Ben
Shapiro and I go okay well what are they
saying what are their arguments here are
compelling responses to them so for
those people I call their bluff and say
and say for the vote for those people
who really do think we want an answer
well here's your answer so now what is
it fair to say that if we are to try to
identify some commonality in terms of
the political philosophy of the movement
it's that it's a libertarian movement of
sorts like it could it could be left
libertarianism or more of a right-wing
libertarianism but that it's
libertarianism in some form that that
unites the movement is that fair yeah I
think that's probably true because a lot
of the people who say because it's a
combination of conservatives who are
obviously very Pro market and then the
people who describe themselves as
classical liberals someone like Dave
Rubin for example who says well I'm a
liberal he used to describe himself as
the last liberal you know I'm on the
Left but I am sort of a critical of it
yeah but actually when you when when you
asked him and I went and interviewed him
Rubin was basically like a free-market
absolutist I mean he was basically
saying I don't see why you need building
regulations and construction codes which
is pretty hard of that conversation yeah
pretty hardcore libertarian position so
you think well okay you and you of the
let you might be of the civil
libertarian laughed but yeah I think
there is I don't see many critics of
capitalism in in that movement yeah I
guess the exception would be maybe Brett
Weinstein right like to some to some
degree I don't know but it seems but
yeah he said he voted for Bernie Sanders
but he doesn't really talk much about
that he hasn't really gone into that
much detail
I don't think about his economic policy
yeah please check out Nathan J
Robinson's book the current affairs
rules for life also don't miss Trump
anatomy of a monstrosity and of course
check out current affairs which Nathan
is the editor of thank you so much for
talking to us about all of this thanks
David this is really fun